[Music]
ah
left important advances to make
[Music] in
addition to cannes
[Music]
as well as facebook
orbán in rule
live from the future is in drama cry  and
breaking like zepa one its extreme
software nuggets become
mediterranean howard johnson and the
materials of europe not only 10 the
world the person
[Music]
the european elections where our
political family has been formed and
confirmed  as the second great
political force in this Europe and with the capacity
to lead a new
pro-European progressive project that confronts the extreme
right and ultra-nationalisms and that
is capable of putting on the table a
project for a renewed strong Europe with
a social pillar  European that
the fight against climate change is the priority objective
a feminist
Europe a solidarity Europe that is capable
of facing the challenges that
our society currently faces  or union project
[Music]